[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous nous sommes des cif et
brasse and co donc le brou pub qui se
trouve sur le plateau nous voulons nous
sommes donc un bar à bière une
microbrasserie un restaurant nous sommes
ouverts en continu de 11 heures jusqu'à
23 heures 30 en semaine et jusqu'à
minuit et demi le vendredi et le samedi
on vous proposera des événements les
événements sportifs des événements
festifs
nous allons pouvoir vous proposer des
bières fait sur place en direct de notre
micro production et cela va permettre de
pouvoir nous proposer par la suite deux
événements en atelier de brassage
pour la carte nous vous proposons donc
un de bières différentes et pour la
carte de restauration nous allons vous
proposer une cuisine type brasserie sur
le midi nous avons une carte à
l'individuel et à l'assiette et le soir
nous allons pouvoir vous proposer des
planches à partager
[Musique]
on vous attend nombreux pour cette année
qui arrive
[Musique]